midair collisions between aircraft and
birds are on the rise partly due to the
increasing number of aircraft sharing
space with birds damage to an aircraft's
windshield utilize Wien leading edges
and jet engines causes delays and
departures delays in missions or
completely puts the aircraft out of
commission until repairs can be made
these are the lucky ones many people
have suffered injury or death when birds
were ingested into engines causing the
aircraft to crash this all cost money
big money
in fact in the United States alone the
civilian and military aviation
communities spend more than 112 million
dollars repairing the over 5,000 bird
strikes reported annually over the years
many products and techniques have been
invented to help clear the runway areas
of airports shell crackers bird bangers
screamers high performance CAPA
long-range pyrotechnics streamer banger
rocket recorded bird distress calls and
repellents make up a facility's arsenal
in its ongoing war against the birds all
of these products are effective and are
necessary components of a successful
animal damage control program we Joseph
international company is the nation's
largest distributor of bird and wildlife
dispersal products over the years one of
the most effective wildlife harassment
tools has been our simple LP gas cannon
however the nature of the regular
interval explosions is one of the things
that hinders their effectiveness Birds
simply become accustomed to the firing
rate of the cannons now there is a
solution to a situation the solution
scare wars scare Wars is a complete bird
and wildlife abatement system that
utilizes the trusted LP canons plus the
bird guard sound generated and
integrates modern technology of computer
control operation that communicates with
the remote bird to tear it units
unlike timer driven LP cannons the scare
world and only fire when safety
personnel see birds around the airfield
habituation is minimized and the element
of surprise is maximized each time the
system is activated since the actual
firing time is dramatically reduced so
is gas consumption airport noise levels
and trips made to the cannons for
refuelling and maintenance the scare
Wars system consists of five basic
components the first is the master
controller this 110 volt AC unit
contains the transceiver which controls
the system commands are transmitted to
the remote bird deterrent units by way
of high-speed digital data a computer
terminal using the advanced graphical
user interface allows the safety officer
to choose which combination of scare
away LP gas cannons will be fired our
new windows 98 based software has many
advantages over our original dos based
product this includes an airfield
diagram which depicts locations of
remote bird deterrent units reporting
functions indicating unit activation
history fuel estimates letting the
operator know the remaining fuel in each
of the LP gas cylinders auto control
allowing the operator to program the
scare Wars system to activate
automatically and with the addition of a
printer printed reports of all
activities may be produced the master
controller computer terminal and base
antenna are usually located in the
control tower or base operations office
the handheld transmitter is the next
major component this portable unit
allows single remote units groups of
remote units or all of the remote
to be activated anywhere on the airfield
giving the roving ground crews another
tool at their disposal
additionally the transmitter can
deactivate the system for scheduled
maintenance the third component is the
solar-powered receiver unit this
galvanized and painted steel cabinet
houses the VHF or UHF receiver LP gas
cylinder valve LP gas cylinder 12 volt
battery and solar panel used to maintain
the battery the weatherproof cabinet
measures approximately three feet in
height two feet in width and two feet in
depth the scare away LP gas cannon can
be mounted directly onto the solar panel
receiver unit or for additional
flexibility the cannon may be placed
nearby and connected to the unit by a
single Sun resistant high-pressure LP
gas hose fitted with quick disconnects
the fourth component and heart of the
system is the scare away LP gas cannon
mounted on a roto mat rotating base when
fired the cannon sound is spread over a
wider area and stops pointed in a
different direction the cannon produces
130 decibels which will easily protect
its assigned area the final component is
the bird guard distress cry generator
consisting of a 200 watt amplifier and
rugged 360-degree outdoor speakers bird
guards are housed in the receiving units
usually on the most critical areas of
the airfield the bird guard blast bird
distress calls on command from the
master the unique combination of cannon
blasts and bird distress
is the element of surprise all scare war
systems are turnkey and installed by our
professional crews maintenance
guarantees are included it must be noted
no animal damage control program will be
successful if used as a set and forget
it system
habitat modification backup with ground
personnel equipped with pyrotechnics and
live rounds shotguns ensure the
effectiveness of this system the scare
Wars radio-controlled bird abatement
system manufactured for and distributed
exclusively by Reed Joseph international
company the most effective easiest to
use economical and most technologically
advanced bird abatement system available
today for more information call 864
seven five five five four or right to
read Joseph's international company p
o-- box eight nine four Greenville
Mississippi three eight 702 or visit our
website at WWF calm